when I was a kid all I wanted to do with
your counsel if you can carry the weight
of being champ in the world in the sport
as a pretty big thing Canada started
this man is unstoppable I've never been
one to ride for second place is win or
not he is the fastest man in the world
right now happens it every sports person
can have injuries they're gonna sit back
cabbage goes down the hardest thing I've
dealt with his epstein-barr virus the
worst thing you can do with it is push
your body it takes takes rest two years
I just don't matter how much a trainer
it felt like I was like under 18 and the
professional world's like I just felt
way out of my depth and it's only now
that I kind of feel human again you kind
of forget what it's like to hurt because
you train an art and I've only recently
got to feel that again that I know I can
make some time through training rather
than the fact I'm sick and that feels
like a win in itself you know that you
can kind of feel like a sportsman again